what we have here is a reaction that
involves iodine manganese oxygen and
hydrogen and what we want to do in this
video is think about which of the
elements are being oxidized in this
reaction and which of the elements are
being reduced in this reaction
and pause this video and see if you can
figure that out before we work through
it together
all right now let's work through it
together and the way that i will tackle
it
and you might have tackled it or i
suggest you tackle it is to figure out
the oxidation numbers for each of the
elements as we go into the reaction as
they are entering the reaction and as
they are exiting the reaction or i guess
you could say on either side of the
reaction
so first let's look at this iodine right
over here well it has a each iodine has
a negative one charge and so it's quote
hypothetical charge which isn't so
hypothetical in this case which would be
its oxidation number is
negative one
now let's move over to this permanganate
ion right over here
now this one's a little bit more
involved to figure out the oxidation
numbers but what we generally remember
is that oxygen is quite electronegative
it is likely to hog two electrons and
when we think about hypothetical charge
with oxidation numbers
oxygen is going to have a negative two
oxidation number because it likes to hog
those two extra electrons
and so if each of these four oxygens has
a hypothetical charge of negative 2 that
would be negative 8 total and we see
that this entire ion has a negative one
charge
so that means that the manganese has to
have a hypothetical charge an oxidation
number of plus
seven so i just want to review that one
again because this is a little bit
involved we said oxygen we're going to
go with a negative 2 because it likes to
hog two electrons
we have four of them so if you add all
that together you're at negative eight
and the whole ion has a negative one
so what plus negative eight is going to
be negative 1 well positive 7 and so
that's manganese's oxidation number as
we enter into the reaction on this side
of the reaction
and then let's look at the water
well water both the hydrogens and
oxygens these are ones you'll see a lot
this oxygen is going to have a negative
two oxidation number and each of those
hydrogen atoms are going to have a plus
one
oxidation number because in that water
molecule if we know that the oxygen hogs
the electrons these are covalent bonds
but if we had to assign kind of a
hypothetical charge where we said all
right well let's just say the oxygen
takes those two electrons then each of
those hydrogens will lose an electron
and have a plus one oxidation number
now let's look at the right hand side of
this reaction
what's going on with these iodines here
well in this iodine molecule they aren't
gaining or losing electrons so your
oxidation number is zero
then let's move on to the next compound
each of these oxygens have an oxidation
number of negative two and so what would
be manganese's oxidation number well the
compound is neutral two oxygens at
negative two is going to be negative
four so in order to be neutral the
manganese must be at plus four an
oxidation number of plus four
and then last but not least if we look
at the these hydroxide anions
each of the oxygen is going to have a
negative two oxidation number
and then the hydrogen is going to have a
plus one and we can confirm that that
makes sense negative 2 plus 1 is going
to be negative 1 for each of these ions
so now let's just think about who's been
oxidized and who's been reduced and
remember oxidation is
losing electrons oil rig reduction is
gaining electrons or reduction is a
reduction in the oxidation number
so first let's look at the iodine we go
from an oxidation number of negative 1
to zero
so to go from an oxidation number of
negative one to zero you need to lose
electrons so it has been oxidized
oxidized
let me write that down the iodine has
been oxidized
now let's look at the manganese we go
from a plus seven to a plus four our
oxidation number has gone down it has
been reduced
now let's look at the oxygen well
everywhere the oxygen has an oxidation
number of negative two so nothing there
and then same thing for the hydrogens
plus one on both sides so nothing there
so the iodine has been oxidized and the
manganese has been reduced